you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news live from cop 26 in glasgow
today marching for their future
thousands of young activists take to the
streets in glasgow demanding action on
climate change
the fridays for future members not in
scotland but kolkata doing their bit to
try and encourage action in the world's
fastest warming city
as the end of the first week of cop 26
approaches cautious optimism from some
that real progress is being made we
assess how much really has been achieved
the impact of deforestation in the
amazon to help supply the multi-million
pound illegal beef trade
and we meet the people behind the
award-winning projects working on
solutions to lower emissions around the
world
[Music]
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show live from the heart of the cop 26
summit in glasgow and the streets here
today have been filled with young
activists who marched past the
conference as events inside marked youth
and public engagement day the strike was
organized for by the fridays for future
movement pioneered by greta thundberg
who today accused the summit of
greenwashing that's misleading the
public into thinking more is being done
for the environment than really is
well she was on that demonstration today
as was our correspondent james matthews
who said this report
[Applause]
outside a glasgow summit that's all
about the future
the future had it safe
this was a march organized by youth
activists a so-called fridays for future
movement greta toonberg vanessa mccarty
at all
through the streets of glasgow it
carried a verdict outside cop26 on the
business inside i think they should just
get their act together
save the planet
we're making people listen and act now
to help save our planets we are here to
say to the world the leader that we are
having
we are running out of time it's
affecting all of us people and we don't
really get to say anything outside of my
protest i'm sick of governments in
action or in fact government native
action on climate change every
revolution started with society doing
something about it
so i believe that the voice of young
people is extremely important especially
in today's day and age
many people certainly among the younger
generation have complained that they
feel excluded from cop 26. the hope here
is that that's mitigated by the vocals
and the visuals
and from climate campaigners on stage a
withering critique
we are in a crisis
we are in a disaster that is happening
every day
this is no longer a climate conference
this is now
a global north greenwash festival
[Applause]
a two-week long celebration of business
as usual and blah blah blah
this youth demonstration proceeded a
global day of action there will be
bigger saturday marches here in glasgow
in london and in cities around the world
while politicians shape the response to
climate change the word on the street
articulates the will of the people
james matthews sky news glasgow
well as we reach the end of the first
week of cop 26 there have been mixed
reviews of how the summit has fared so
far in its aim of reaching a consensus
on how to keep global warming to 1.5
degrees above pre-industrial levels
former u.s vice president al gore warned
the climate crisis is getting worse but
john kerry struck a more optimistic note
today
the majority of the g20 have real plans
that they have laid out included in
their ndc's
that will keep 1.5 degrees alive
that's
a game
changer way beyond what many people
thought was possible
so let's take a look then at the main
developments from the summit so far well
on monday india the world's third
largest emitter put a date on reaching
net zero by 2070 and the prime minister
narendra modi promised his country would
get half its energy from renewable
sources by the end of this decade
tuesday saw more than 100 countries
representing 85 of the world's forests
signed up to end deforestation by 2030
including brazil
more than 100 nations also pledged to
cut emissions methane emissions by at
least 30 percent before the end of the
decade
cutting the powerful greenhouse gas is
seen as the quickest way to slow global
warming
progress on money came next japan
promised 10 billion dollars more towards
climate finance for developing countries
meaning rich countries have very nearly
reached the annual 100 billion dollar
target
and financial institutions announced 130
trillion dollars in assets would be
available to invest in the push to net
zero
and yesterday more than 40 countries
pledged to phase out coal the dirtiest
fossil fuel signatories included poland
ukraine and vietnam but not australia
the u.s or china
well our technology and science editor
tom clark reports now on what's been
achieved so far
the conference that ends climate change
or a flop spilling hot air what's the
mood a week into cop26
i think we still have quite a long way
to go so far so good tensions of
contradictions
but i am i am
optimistic the goals that have been
announced are not going to be enough i
think to achieve the goals that were set
the uk presidency marshaled big
political announcements on forests
finance on phasing out coal deals that
could shave crucial tenths of degrees of
projected global warming
but they're not enough that requires
every single government to actually
deliver on all the commitments that
they've made it's not enough to make
commitments you have to follow through
with action as well and that's why it is
not job done by any stretch of the
imagination i want us to leave here
being able to save the credibility that
we have kept 1.5 within reach
his position not helped by some pledges
already fraying at the edges indonesia
today rowing back on its promise to end
deforestation by 2030. poland named in a
press release as having made ambitious
pledges on cutting coal won't actually
do so until 2049. they may be fragile
but these pledges and promises raised
hopes way higher than they were when
this great climate road show began
but away from the crowds and the slogans
teams of negotiators are still arguing
over these texts the rules of the paris
agreement and until they're signed off
the world doesn't really have a process
by which can fairly cut carbon emissions
it's what this summit is all about
will enough nations yield for
negotiations to advance your excellency
hello i'm tom from sky news hi enter
costa rica which diverted its defense
budget into welfare and environment 70
years ago with a message of
encouragement we're talking about a life
and death for all of humanity so does it
make any sense to invest in military or
wage commercial wars when we are facing
perhaps the doom of the fate of humanity
the likelihood of success well a good
judge is the former french pm laurel
fabius the father of the paris agreement
we come to the question of what we call
rule book the question of finance to
question ambition and to the question of
transparency and these are the main
elements
uh to say at the end of the cup and only
at the end of the cup
is it a success or failure and i know by
experience that there is not a big
difference between the two on monday
high level talks begin which will help
dictate which side of that fine line our
futures fall
tom clark sky news glasgow
well let's take a look now some of the
day's other climate news from cop and
from around the world and a huge iceberg
from greenland appeared outside cop 26
in glasgow today in a bid to remind
delegates that the arctic is in crisis
the greenland ice sheet is the second
largest on earth but has been losing 247
billion tons of ice per year over the
previous decade
carbon dioxide emissions of the richest
1
are expected to reach 70 tons of co2 per
person a year if governments don't
constrain luxury carbon consumption of
private jets mega yachts and space
travel new research shows they'll
account for 16 of total emissions by
2030 while the poorest 50 percent will
be releasing an average of one tonne of
co2 annually
and air pollution in india's capital
delhi surged to its highest level this
year the day after diwali celebrations
across the country the air quality index
reached 451 on a scale of 500 in the
city indicating severe conditions
affecting people's health
well to the amazon now where the impacts
of deforestation are well known but one
story that isn't often told is that of
illegal and unregulated beef production
rainforest cattle are part of a
multi-million pound conspiracy with
animals raised on land that's been
illegally cleared mixed in with
legitimate stock and sold on the global
market our chief correspondent stuart
ramsey has been to satarum in brazil's
paris state and this is his story on
brazil's illegal beef trade and a
warning his report contains pictures of
a cow being mistreated
these steers are unregistered and
illegal they have no legitimate markings
some have yellow tags indicating only
that they've been sold
they're from the amazon rainforest from
farms that have no legitimacy the land
has been stolen
but these cattle will eventually enter
the world's food supply chain re-badged
as legal
it's a conspiracy worth millions
beef washing with the amazon at its
heart the vital link between climate
change and cattle is simple
eighty percent of the forest being cut
down here is carried out by ranchers
the amazon is being destroyed so that
you can eat beef
this is what it looks like when the
farmers move in
the trees simply disappear
never to return
this is para state in the amazon and it
looks like this everywhere you go
brazil is the world's number one
exporter of beef much of it at the
expense of the forest that keeps the
planet breathing
a recent audit of the world's biggest
meat packing company found it had bought
over 300 thousand cows from paris state
that had irregularities basically beef
washed into the regular market from
rainforest farms
the animals are transported hundreds of
miles by truck you see them everywhere
you go
there are 210 steer in these two lorries
they've been traveling for seven days
with no food or water
they've been parked here for hours
the metal of the truck is so hot you
can't touch it
farmers tell us that the steers can lose
up to 35 kilograms each just from the
travel
this unregulated and illegal business is
rarely seen
sky news given unparalleled access into
this murky world of beef production by
unrepentant farmers who believe it is
their right
element
[Music]
exhausted from days in a truck for a few
hours these steers arrested before the
next part of their journey a river
transporter barge on a tributary of the
amazon
they're driven towards the metal loading
ramp of the barge
[Applause]
slipping and sliding and tramping on
each other with no regulation no
controls and certainly no vets their
well-being appears to be utterly
ignorable
one of the steers doesn't make it up the
ramp and gets stuck
so began over an hour of brutal efforts
to get him to move
the ranchers start by kicking him in his
face
trying to rile him to stand
clearly in terrible distress the man
then force his head underwater
i hope the steer fearing he is drowning
will be spurred on
the animal must be terrified he
struggles forward and collapses
legs splayed apart
he's badly injured now and he still
isn't on board
anyone who's seen animals being treated
particularly when they're being taken
away to slaughter know that it's pretty
gruesome but this is very nasty
incidents and that animal is absolutely
exhausted the point is it's all part of
unregulated trade
nobody knows where that beef is going to
end up it could be in britain it could
be in europe it could be in argentina it
could be in brazil and that's the real
issue here nobody's across what's
happening and of course
the treatment any of the sort of usual
strictures don't really exist
and finally they resort to a block and
tackle
ropes are tied around the horns
and he is slowly hauled into the barge
this beef will eventually be certified
and exported
and none of us will ever know it came
from the rainforest
produced to satisfy demand
stuart ramsey sky news in the amazon
kolkata in india is the world's fastest
warming city climate change and rapid
urbanization have made it hotter and
more vulnerable to extreme weather and
while fridays for future activists
protest in glasgow katharina pitotsi met
three young members of the movement in
the city where their future is under
threat
climate change is something that will
hamper our fundamental right to life
if we do not take actions immediately we
won't be
having a habitable future ahead of us
so uh it's very important that people uh
understand that and come out of the
bubble that they're living in
i understand you're part of a bigger
movement but how do you feel personally
about
the future
you see for yourself
possibly for your children
and the generations that come after
future i think it'll
foreign
what would you like to see
changed or what decisions would you like
to see being made at
cop26 we would like to see the
participation of global south
more
in the fight for climate justice because
global south is
the region which will be the earliest
and the most affected by climate crisis
we are already seeing climate refugees
in global south if we could hear the
voices of the people earlier if we could
listen to them if the leaders were not
misleading us then the problem wouldn't
be
so severe that it is right now
and leave us in a position where you
say
we have to do the seemingly impossible
and you can see katarina's documentary
about life in one of the world's most
climate vulnerable places this evening
that's climate crisis life on the front
line here on sky news at 9 00 pm
now the cop 26 summit offers a chance to
highlight some of the climate solutions
that will be crucial in achieving a net
zero future and the ashton awards do
just that celebrating projects working
to lower carbon emissions around the
world so here's a look at some of this
year's winners
my name is imam barmacki and i support
local authorities up and down the
country to decarbonize their heating
systems
[Music]
my name is penny baba's atheist
my work at nunes nexus helps local women
and youth groups
to distribute clean energy products
my name is naras and i am a syrian
refugee
the welcoming growing site in edinburgh
gives people a connection to their
history
my name is anika kele and when i was
young my dad used to call us citizens of
the planet
we've started a program to train
contractors and how to retrofit homes
my name is noah senpija
we focus on encouraging people mainly
women
young people
and refugees to move away from
destructive farming methods to more
organic and sustainable practices
my name is vigil brahmbat
we work with women-led community action
groups
across
1666 slum settlements in india
to taste
sustainable cooling technologies
[Music]
well we're discussing all of the climate
issues of the day now and i'm joined by
fatima ibrahim co-director of the green
new deal uk and evelyn acham a climate
change activist from uganda so welcome
to both of you
even to you first of all you've traveled
all the way from uganda to come to
glasgow
to join in that rally and protest on the
streets and come here to the conference
too why have you decided to come
because
first of all so many people really
wanted to come but they did not have a
chance to because you have a child
[Music]
[Music]
and i'm here and again my country is
among the communities that are
experiencing the climate crisis
firsthand we are experiencing disasters
like floods
like droughts that are drying up
people's crops people's water because my
country depends on our culture and our
survival and yet the agriculture is
being affected by climate change so we
are being hit
very hard right now people are dying of
starvation homes are being washed away
by blood schools are being washed away
by floods so i'm here to speak up to the
leaders to the world leaders to let them
understand that for us
already the present is so hard for us
it's catastrophic we are suffering some
of the worst impacts and we demand
action we cannot wait for more years as
they say that
by 2030 uh they'll be able to do this
some of us cannot wait for the years to
reach before they act we want them to
act now so we are here i am here to
delight for climate justice
so fatima even's voice is one of those
heard of a rally today meanwhile inside
the conference it's been youth day do
you think in here they're hearing the
voices of those young people outside
like england i mean clearly our world
leaders and the negotiators in here are
hearing young people
at home and over the last year because
they've come here and they've made some
big pretty big pledges and it's worth
recognizing these pledges are because
there's such a demand on the outside
particularly by young people who have
been out there striking who've out been
out there protesting and a lot of these
leaders are worried to go home without
delivering and promising something but
at the same time it's worth recognizing
that these are just pledges and that
they need to deliver on those promises
and in here there was a youth strike
also held within the within the cup
itself um for the young people who are
here there are young people who are
trying to engage in the negotiations
it's not always easy and they haven't
been given access to necessarily all of
the rooms where they should be present
and be able to um participate in the
negotiations but there are young people
here too even do you feel listened to do
you feel heard
to access the negotiation rooms so we
are not so sure what was really
discussed we simply saw the reports and
the pledges that leaders have fed and
again some voices are being left out
like the people of color we just saw
recently uh
recently vanessa's photo and peter bug
and
the prime the minister
of sportsland i don't remember very well
but
yeah i mean no no no no no the first
president the first minister in the
classroom
yeah and so um they later cropped her
out again so this is like always leaving
out a certain race yeah so we we i'm not
so sure they're listening to us because
they're still under representation yes
this group has
a number of people from africa and the
global south but it's still not enough
and we heard criticism from greta
thunderberg today talking about green
washing here at the conference she
talked about it being a two-week
celebration of business as usual and
blah blah blah do you think she's got a
point do you think she's right or or are
you worried some people have expressed
worry that the criticism isn't that
helpful they say that people are trying
their best here what do you think i'm
with bretta i mean they've been
negotiating literally my whole lifetime
for 28 years these cops have been
happening and we're still you know
headed towards climate disaster so i
don't think anyone can blame young
people when they look at these pledges
and go blah blah blah like what we need
to see is action so i think that
criticism is accurate okay fatima
ibrahim evelyn
thank you both very much indeed
so don't forget you can listen to a new
climate cast every day from cop26
wherever you normally find your podcasts
and meanwhile you may already be
watching this on our pop-up channel but
if not you can find uninterrupted
coverage from cop 26 between 9 a.m and 7
p.m on channel 525 and sky glass channel
505. thanks for watching see
[Music]